chance also joining cardi B&T eye on a
new Netflix series rhythm in flow and
they're trying to find the next hip-hop
sensation who can beat the odds just
like cardi B did girl my my teachers
always something I was gonna be somebody
I don't know why did you deep down know
it huh it's so so it's like when you get
turned down so many times you just start
like not believing it but then you keep
hearing it like you're such a star
you're gonna be somebody now that she's
a bona fide showbiz success what does it
take to impress cardi and her fellow
judge TI well it's all about the fashion
so what's the biggest thing that someone
could do to impress you when they came
in front of you me looks will you talk
about the look and how important that is
so I have a little look for both of you
off let's look at it oh yes honey yes
honey could you really not see it was
really blurry it was like I couldn't
really see much this is my Tupac tribute
[Music]
I'm proud of this look because not many
people could have done it
[Music]
[Applause]